je me suis souvent demandé jusqu'où
pouvait aller par amitié on dit qu'on
choisit pas sa famille on peut dire
qu'on a choisi la nôtre depuis qu'on se
connaît on rêve d'habiter ensemble je
viens de vous trouver un put
d'appartements vous mettez 500 chacun je
paye tout le reste tant que samuel
continue ses soi-disant est une de
médecine s'étaient pas docteur je dors
jamais parlé mais sécheresse vaginale le
rachis son père continue lui donner de
l'oseille profiter de mon argent en
faisant croire tu fais des études tu
recevras plus un centime de ma part
quand on n'a plus de famille restés amis
je suis en scooter tu veux je te défonce
se pose pas et tu veux chez les pauses
je pense que tu as mais là c'est sûr
maintenant chose merde mais je te
propose qu'on s'associe pour fait 55 ans
tous les deux sont des manières tu ne
sais pas un mois aux autres ça reste
entre nous bangle qu'est ce que c'est
que cette dégaine de merde tommy kaira
des années 90 on va mieux il mafieux
italiens de merde en eau
maintenant c'est moi qui parle qui es-tu
louvre pas on n'est pas dans gta like
puis samedi bon bien sûr elle plan est
simple vous donne quatre kilos d'herbe
on les vendait pour me ramener les 20000
euros dimanche matin à 8h fait ce n'est
pas déjà merci parce que l'explication a
été limpide pontacq vraiment trop con et
sa diction ramener parlera nous ferait
bouffer nokoué mutuellement 1169 qui
m'ont un peu le [ __ ] on est à dire
mais comme ce à quoi on imagine qu'il
mettrait un peu en tête bêche en fait
pour ainsi dire mais au niveau des
coudes en fait c'est wasquehal et mahdia
l'arrêté coup de tête bêche là
mais nous on s'est dit qu'on pouvait
vous rendre la drogue parce qu'on en a
plus du tout l'utilité en chine